[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
que los lleva a dar una vuelta al mundo
de la mano de nuestra red de periodistas
soy herminia Fernández por Andrés
espinal en Italia el sistema sanitario
público esté centralizado y depende de
cada región esto crea enormes
disparidades entre las zonas más ricas
del Norte y las pobres el sur que
presentan más problemas en el área de
atención cadáver es uno de estos lugares
pobres y desde 2010 su sector sanitario
se encuentra bajo supervisión Estatal
debido a las enormes deudas acumuladas Y
al alto riesgo de caer en bancarrota en
los últimos 20 años 18 de 42 hospitales
de calabria han cerrado sus puertas y no
se encuentran médicos que quieran
trabajar allí frente a esta crisis las
autoridades regionales han contactado
las misiones médicas internacionales de
Cuba Natalia Mendoza Luis manuá y cloe
Duval nos traen la historia
no hay tiempo que perder esta paciente
está sufriendo un infarto en este
hospital de polistena en el sur de
calabria entre los médicos de la unidad
de urgencias hay una cara nueva El
doctor no elmarrego un especialista en
reanimación recién llegado de la isla de
Cuba
y yo trabajo en una terapia intensiva en
la provincia de Cienfuegos tengo ya más
de 20 años de experiencia no solo en
Cuba estaba en luanda en Angola y en
Venezuela también No él hace parte de
una brigada de 51 doctores cubanos
contratados por la región de calabria El
objetivo hacer frente a la escasez
crónica de personal que tiene los
hospitales de la región al borde del
colapso la reanimación la unidad de
reanimación ha tenido que cerrar
temporalmente por falta de anestesistas
y reanimadores ahora desde que llegaron
los colegas cubanos la situación ha
mejorado son personas bien preparadas
mirar en este hospital los médicos
cubanos han sido asignados a varios
repartos como cardiología o radiología
es aquí en donde la doctora Daily Ramos
radióloga originaria de matanzas en el
norte de Cuba realiza una mamografía yo
me siento muy feliz muy útil muy
realizada he visto como los pacientes
agradecen que se realicen los estudios
aquí en su localidad y no tener que
viajar al norte a hacerse estudios me
siento en buenas manos la doctora me
explicó muy bien la situación mejor que
como lo hacen los italianos me parece
excelente que estos doctores vengan a
Italia a ayudarnos y a cumplir con su
deber les agradezco gracias la región
garantiza cada médico un contrato de un
año renovable pagado Al mismo nivel que
los médicos italianos
cuando abro concursos públicos de
contratación los médicos italianos no
participan o los que se inscriben y
ganan deciden después irse a otras
regiones italianas porque no quieren
venir a calabria
en total el acuerdo prevé la llegada de
hasta 497 médicos cubanos en los
próximos dos años
el gobierno del presidente de Chile
Gabriel Boris cumplió recientemente un
año uno de los problemas que aqueja a la
población desde que comenzó su mandato
es la inflación que cerró en 2022 con un
12,8%, la mayor en 30 años Aunque en
febrero retrocedió el
0,1%, el alza de precios se está
ahogando la economía de los más
vulnerables nuestra corresponsal
Patricia Luna junto con Adrián mansol
nos cuentan más
krishna ayuda a su padre en un puesto
del mercado central de la Vega la vega
Es el lugar que visitan en la actualidad
muchos santiaguinos para esquivar Los
Altos precios de los alimentos como
consecuencia de la inflación anualizada
del más de 12%, hace más de tres décadas
que los chilenos no experimentaban Un
aumento tan alto en los alimentos en lo
que es la fruta la verdura se ha subido
mucho Ya que en las plantaciones el
abono está caro todo está caro en
realidad todo ya va subiendo Clara es
una pensionada y vino al mercado
buscando precios bajos evalúa muy bien
lo que va a comprar los pocos más de 200
dólares mensuales que recibe por
jubilación de media a los chilenos No
son suficientes para cubrir las
necesidades básicas y Clara debe medir
bien cómo gasta sus ingresos con una
precaución increíble
Porque nada alcanza está horriblemente
caro se compra lo que usted es necesario
pero también tratando de no perder la
calidad de las cosas por eso se viene a
la que es más barato
Este es mi refrigerador
último día del mes la situación de Ana
quien gana sueldo mínimo ya debido
Buscar un segundo trabajo no es muy
diferente su novela luce casi vacía y se
angustia porque cada vez compra menos
Colón que gana y no es suficiente para
alimentar a su familia el sueldo no da
para nada más que para medio vivir O sea
la quincena el sueldo se acabó hoy día
la alimentación también es mala para
nosotros los pobres porque nos vemos
obligados a comer arroz y fideo aunque
en el mes de febrero la inflación de un
pequeño respiro en Chile por primera vez
en 27 meses los chilenos siguen
preocupados por los precios altos
mejorar la economía se mantiene como uno
de los principales retos pendientes en
el segundo año de gobierno de boric que
apenas comienza en marzo de 2017 41
jóvenes murieron calcinadas en Guatemala
en un centro de menores que debía
cuidarlas ya han pasado seis años y la
reparación de los familiares poco
avanzado nuestros corresponsales en
Centroamérica Andrés Suárez
nos cuentan La batalla de los padres y
sobrevivientes por esclarecer las
circunstancias de la tragedia que aún no
tiene culpables
41 globos para 41 niñas a quienes se les
arrebató la vida en la ciudad de
Guatemala se conmemora el sexto
aniversario del incendio de un hogar
para menores a cargo de listado
yo empecé a llorar porque yo pensé que
estaba quemada al ver a las demás así
porque yo pienso que
que en otros países con una niña que si
hubiera quemado así y hubieran
reaccionado Y por qué nuestro gobierno
nuestro estado nuestra Guatemala No no
ha dado respuestas realmente Mayra aidé
chután Urías que exigimos
después de seis años el juicio aplazado
12 veces no ha empezado
ha habido toda clase de estrategias de
parte de la defensa por ejemplo no
asistir a las audiencias reportarse
enfermos que por una u otra razón que el
tráfico
los padres Aún se mantienen de pie
reclamando justicia heridas salguero
madre de Keyla una joven de 17 años que
perdió la vida en ese incendio aún no
asimila la pérdida de su hija como que
key la me las hubiera mandado a mí el
montón de rosas
para su mamá que no esté triste que ella
está conmigo siempre en el tiempo que
ocurrió el incendio las menores del
hogar seguro venían denunciando golpizas
abusos sexuales e incluso trata de
personas porque las niñas las abusaban
por eso es que ellos quieren que esto se
quede así no quieren que esto siga
verdad para que haya una justicia porque
saben que queremos llegar al punto de la
violencia que ellos estaban sufriendo
ahí adentro
varias familias de víctimas afirman ser
blanco de amenazas aún así han decidido
que no dejarán de alzar la voz para
conseguir justicia por la muerte de sus
hijas
en Bolivia se ha registrado más de
13.000 casos de dengue y las muertes
sobrepasan las cuarenta la mayoría han
sido niños en Santa Cruz donde está el
73% de ocurrencias se ha habilitado un
hospital de campaña y las mamás rezan
por sus hijos en las puertas de los
centros médicos pero la enfermedad no
está dando tregua a las familias
cruceñas Mary vaca y Javier Arriaga con
los detalles
Isabel Montenegro vive en Santa Cruz
donde el dengue está causando estragos
para combatirlo participa en una jornada
comunitaria de limpieza eliminando los
recipientes con agua donde anida el
mosquito transmisor aedes appy todo eso
que es criadero de mosquito y que no se
puede reutilizar porque ya está muy
oxidado muy viejo lo estamos llevando
para que se lo lleve el camión de la
minga hace poco la enfermedad llegó a su
hogar le dio a mi hijito a uno de 9 años
hace unas tres semanas atrás siete días
estuvo delicado los hospitales súper
saturados ahora Isabel ha redoblado sus
esfuerzos para sacar las botellas de
casa los funcionarios han fumigado
varios barrios de Santa Cruz y cargado
toda la basura
para responder a la saturación de los
hospitales un centro de campaña recibe a
los enfermos en carpas Así que ahorita
me lo van a internar aquí el hospital al
aire libre que fue donado por Estados
Unidos se ha convertido en una opción
para las familias que buscan ayuda de
forma desesperada son hospitales de
campaña en el país para poder responder
a emergencias y desastres en el hospital
del niño muchas mamás rezan por la
recuperación de sus hijos
la principal dirigente de los médicos
acusa a las autoridades de negligencia
por la muerte de los niños el dengue en
sí como enfermedad si estuviera pasado
en otra parte del mundo donde un sistema
no estuviera colapsado un sistema de
salud no hubiera habido tanta mortalidad
acciones preventivas como las de Isabel
y las limpiezas colectivas son
importantes para contener la enfermedad
que ya deja más de 40 muertos sin
embargo por más que se eliminen los
criaderos de mosquitos en Santa Cruz
nada Parece ser suficiente contra la
epidemia
hasta aquí el programa corresponsales de
la semana nuestro agradecimiento al café
mariposa de cristal por permitirnos
grabar el programa en sus instalaciones
síganos por France 24 y por France
24.com
[Música]